(fanfare)
- Le jour de l'Indépendance,
heheher aux Américains,
tourne au drame ce matin
dans cette banli
Ces familles à l'arrière
est en train de se produire
et tentent de fuir le plus
rapidement possible.
Cet homme croyait que des
soldats de lriririne rendaient
hommage au drapeau, mais quand
il a vu tout le monde courirnfn.
Comme des milliers de personnes
il a laissé derrière ses e d d ,
certains ont abandonné
des poussettes. Pour le sauver
des balles il a même caché
à ordures.
"J'ai vu au moins troispersonn,
raconte cet autre témoin.
Un moment
devient une opération policière.
Selon les autorités,'u'u'u'u'ue
personnes ont été touchées.
Le présumé tireur, un jeune
homme de 22 ans originaire de la
après une chasse à l'hommeququqt
au moment de la fusillade,
une arme très puissante, dit-il,
a été retrouvée sur les lieux.
Le président Biden se félicite
d'avoir fait adopter, dit-il,
la
contrôle des armes à feu depuis
près de 30 ans, m c c convient-
il, il reste du travail à faire.
Depuis la fusillade dans uneTeTn
du mois de mai, plus de 95
fusillades dites de masse, donc
qui ont fait plus de quatre
aux États-Unis, faisant
plus1111115 victimes.galegalegat
secoués par des manifestations
à la suite de la mort d'un autre
jeune homme noir abattu
Par des manifestations aussi
contre la déononon de
la Cour suprême de révoquer
le droit à l'avortement.
Une note d'optimisme
besoin d'un peu de lumière.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Washington.